But if you want to do something with
the user interface
or if you want to create code with
the user interface, like code as the interface,
I think TypeScript
with its rich
generic
capabilities,
it's the perfect language
for a user interface. If we think, you
know, not buttons, but for developers, the user
interface is the language. And I think TypeScript
is actually the best language
to create
amazing
developer experiences.
Like, that that's that's my love for for
TypeScript. So everything that should be super fast,
I would say,
go. Everything that should be
pleasant to use, TypeScript, and everything that should
be super safe,
I would go Rust.